hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute hier aus dem sellicon Valley wir
werden heute hier einen richtig leckeren
Kuchen backen und nebenher räume ich
auch noch die Küche ein
ist aber ein anderes Video
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich packe heute einen Zucchini
Schokoladenkuchen der ist so saftig und
so lecker die Bitte dir lieben warum
bewege ich meine Hand nicht weil ich da
einen Fleck auf der
und ich habe nur die Schürze dabei ich
hatte nämlich Make-up an der Hand und
danach egal was erkläre ich denn dann es
ist ein richtig leckerer
Schokoladenkuchen der ist sehr saftig
ist weil ich Zucchini mit rein nehme ihr
könnt statt Zucchini auch Kürbis oder
Karotten nehmen schmeckt auch beides
super und es sorgt einfach nur dafür
dass der Kuchen mega saftig ist ich
zeige euch mal die Zutaten ihr verwendet
dafür 180g weiche Butter 180 g
Zartbitterschokolade drei Eier 130 Gramm
braunen Zucker etwas Salz und Tonka
Paste 130 g Mehl plus Backpulver oder
ihr nehmt das backmehl 30g Kakao 130 g
Zucchini und eine Zitrone zuerst nehmt
ihr jetzt die Butter und schmelzt sie in
der Mikrowelle oder auf dem Herd bei
niedriger Stufe und dann schalte ich den
Herd aus und in der Rest Wärme werde ich
dann die Schokolade dazu schmelzen
in der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal
die Eier mit dem Zucker Salz und mit der
Tonka Paste verrühren einfach so ein
bisschen cremig
[Musik]
in der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr dann hier
die Zucchini noch reiben die
Zitronenschale abreiben und den Saft
ausfressen echt ein Video wo man mich
auch sieht so ja man sieht dich jetzt
auch also kannst dich ruhig mit mir
unterhalten Alex sieht man hier auch
Daniela sieht man auch diese Küche ist
super super schön ich habe auch in der
Küche glaube ich noch nie ein Video
gedreht aber wir sind gerade dabei
kitchen Folge hier fertig zu machen das
heißt ich bin den ganzen Tag schon am
Küche einrichten sortieren umräumen und
am schauen wie ich bestmöglich für euch
ein tolles Ordnungssystem schaffen kann
und dann haben wir gedacht komm jetzt
machen wir noch ein Rezept Video
zwischendrin
damit ihr an einem Sonntag nicht ohne
rezept
aber ich muss sozusagen bald machen wir
eine Sommerpause da gibt's dann keine
langen großen Videos mehr es gibt dann
noch ein paar Shorts und Reals aber über
den Sommer hinweg haben wir uns gedacht
machen wir eine kleine Sommerpause
damit ihr euch von uns erholen könnt
und wir neue Kraft tanken
hier noch die Zitrone
[Musik]
alle Zutaten da rein das geht wirklich
ganz ganz schnell ihr braucht auch keine
Küchenmaschine ihr könnt doch einfach
mit dem Handrührgerät arbeiten die
trockenen Zutaten rein und die flüssige
Butter mit der Schokolade kurz verrühren
ab in die Backform und ab in den Ofen
Alex machst du mir einfach den Ofen auf
ich hoffe
Assistentin
danke Alex
[Musik]
der Kuchen ist gebacken und ist auch
schon fast komplett abgekühlt jetzt
gibt's da noch eine Ganache drauf und
zwar besteht die aus Sahne und
Zartbitterkuvertüre die Sahne kocht ihr
jetzt einfach kurz auf
und dann kann ich in der Zwischenzeit
den Kuchen schon mal darüber setzen
ich weiß noch wie das damals war als wir
von unserer Wohnung in die studioküche
gezogen sind und ich muss mal gucken was
das erste Video aus dem Studio war ich
weiß nur damals war die erste Sendung
also diese einfach Sally Sendung aus dem
Studium und nach jeder Zeit zur boah die
alte Küche war viel cooler und viel
schöner und da sieht man immer wie das
so ist wenn man dann aus einem gewohnten
Umfeld in so ein ungewohntes kommt und
jetzt denkt sich jeder Studio Küche
richtig cool und jetzt stehe ich hier
ist eine komplett andere Küche und für
mich ist es ungewohnt aber ich finde es
jetzt nicht unbedingt schlechter so je
länger ich mich hier aufhalten
dann den Herd aus und Schmelz die
Schokolade drin
[Musik]
jetzt noch hier Khao nips drauf und
gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren kommt wir
probieren jetzt den Kuchen ich habe
übrigens parallel noch einen Kuchen
gebacken ja und ich habe den
Hauswirtschaftsraum aufgeräumt ich weiß
alle sind hier am Räumen und es ist
schon los es ist schon so spät am Abend
aber wir haben jetzt gedacht komm wir
probieren das jetzt also das ist ein
Schokokuchen und hier habe ich noch was
neues ausprobiert dachte mir so komm ich
bin gerade mit zwei Kuchen den habe ich
jetzt nicht gefilmt den zweiten hier
aber ich dachte mir probiert denn jetzt
trotzdem und wenn er euch auch so gut
schmeckt wie mir dann mache ich dann
auch mal als Video okay also probiert
jetzt alle einfach mal Kuchen
und dann dürft ihr auch gerne mal die
Küche bestaunen wie schön sie
eingerichtet ist da mache ich nämlich
gerade ein separates video
m
läuft bei dir
hast du dann Marienkäfer besonders
der ist auch irgendwie so schön fluffig
aber auch so
der ist so leicht ab der schmeckt
trotzdem so ich sag mal die bittere Note
wegen es ist tatsächlich Schokolade
im Abgang ja und schmeckt schon die die
heidelbe raus egal
der auch gut
also das eine ist ein Zucchinikuchen und
das eine ist ein Karottenkuchen
der ist doch hammermäßig saftig
wir kümmern uns noch um den Kuchen
beide Kuchen richtig lecker also
Schokokuchen Rezept gibt es ab jetzt auf
meinem Kanal in meiner App schaut gerne
an ihr könnt daraus auch Muffins
zubereiten ihr könnt ein Kastenkuchen
backen aber ich finde so einfach lecker
ihr habt Zucchini die ihr verwerten
könnt es ist ein richtig leckerer
saftiger Schokoladenkuchen und wenn man
nicht sagt dass dazu keine drin steckt
merkt auch wirklich keiner und den
anderen Kuchen hier den mit Karotte den
backe ich bei der nächsten Gelegenheit
nach wenn ihr wollt denn der ist
wirklich richtig gut den kann man
übrigens auch richtig toll vegan
Zubereiten der ist so gut boah
wir kommen also macht's gut bis zum
nächsten Mal ich mache jetzt noch die
Küche fertig und irgendwann demnächst
kommt auch das Küchen Video online ich
zeig dann einfach so ein paar Tipps und
Tricks macht so eine ich mache einfach
so eine wie wäre es wenn wir dieses
Küchen Video einfach als roomtour machen
eine roomtour durch die Silicon Valley
hier schreibt gerne in die Kommentare
dann machen wir das so fertig
[Musik]